I think the important distinction here
Mario is that these banks Citigroup now
bank america credit agricole prior to
that are reducing their financing but
it's not like they're cutting off
financing completely right that's true
there they come out and said they're
going to dial back the financing and the
lending to some of the to the coal
industry particularly toward those that
engage in a practice of what's called
mountaintop mining where you essentially
cut off the top of a mountain just to
get to the coal seams but as you said
it's important to note that there this
is a dial back but not a full-out
elimination but nevertheless it's going
to squeeze the guys that were already
feeling the pain like an article Alpha
Natural Resources and the funny thing is
the cola still used to generate forty
percent of the world's power right so we
still need it so what happens as that
financing get squeezed that's true if
you imagine Cain coal is this big Santa
Claus like figure for the last I don't
know two centuries or so it's going
through a dramatic diet right now and
it's gone it's headed into this term is
overused but it's true nonetheless it's
going to a new normal where it has to
slim down the world is moving away from
Colditz reducing that exposure
particularly Western nations and such as
countries in Europe and the United
States